meanwhile uh somebody else in that party
is nancy pelosi and the you know uh the
olympics you're going to see the opening
ceremonies tonight if you watch
i mean i don't know anybody who's
excited about this year's olympics
here's here's the thing they're being
held in beijing china and china is a
very famous human rights violator for a
variety of reasons so
the speaker of the house had a message
to these athletes who
after they compete there's a press
conference and she made it very clear
whatever you do don't say anything bad
about china watch
you're there to compete
do not risk
incurring the anger of the chinese
government because they are ruthless
i know there is a temptation on the part
of some
to speak out while they are there
i respect that
but i also worry
about what the chinese government might
do
i mean everyone does think that but that
is insane that we're sending
we're we're actually taking part in this
and we're going to the
right go there participate in your sport
and keep your mouth closed yeah at the
press conference don't say what you
really think you will be asked by a
reporter keep in mind she can't say hey
reporters don't ask those questions
because that would be an infringement on
a reporter but she can't say hey if
you're representing the united states
don't say anything bad although think
about it if you're an olympic athlete
and you are in front of the world's
press that is the number one time to say
something because after the olympics and
that's what they're suggesting what'd
you get home nobody's gonna care then
when you're right there that would be
the maximum time to do it that's exactly
what what enos cantor freedom remember
he's from turkey got his citizenship
changed his name to freedom listen to
what he said
i mean i actually did sort of a video
just 30 minutes ago and it broke my
heart because you know at least i feel
like needs to use their platform to
bring awareness of what's going on
around the world and obviously china
right now is the biggest human right
abuses in the world and so i feel like i
mean to all the athletes my message is
you know while you're there take it one
take it one or one or two a day and
visit
the concentration camps if you can you
know see what tibetans or hong kongs are
going through take another trip to
taiwan and see what what democracy means
so when i saw that video it definitely
did
break my heart
so uh so yeah right and he was talking
about yao ming and he said yao ming the
big seven foot five chinese uh former
houston rocket chinese national he came
out and he kind of challenged dennis
cantor and then invited him over and
then uh
sounds good i'll come over and let's
make sure we go see uh the uyghurs and
let's go go visit hong kong and then he
blocked him on twitter so i guess uh
then he just called him out as a big man
with who's actually small
india will skip the opening ceremonies
which start in five minutes
because they will not attend because the
torch bearer reportedly chosen by the
chinese authorities rallied riled up new
delhi's anger india's foreign affairs
spokesperson on thursday said it was
regrettable that the chinese side had
chosen to politicize an event like the
olympics the they actually thought they
were going to go to the olympics and not
have it politicized there's no fans
there's no broadcasting there's no
broadcasters in the country so you are
going to look at i understand why japan
did it but there's no way that china
should be doing it when you we put 101
000 people in the michigan stadium you
should be able to put some people in an
arena even their family members can't go
if that were your child would you want
to be there so you're not allowed to
bring your family and you're not allowed
to talk that's just one of the things
that threw off so simone biles evidently
she was so out of her uh element because
there was no one around also uh it it
could be you know when you see the
athlete if you watch the opening
ceremonies later uh as it will be
broadcast here in the united states if
you are watching you may know if unless
you count you might actually be missing
some american athletes because some
american athletes apparently feel so
strongly about human rights violations
of china they don't want to take part in
it but rather than announce that they're
not doing it they're just gonna sit in
the olympic village they too will not
say hey i have a little silent protest
until after the games and they're back
here in america where they can speak
freely and say three and a half weeks
it's crazy i went i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now